[Music]
when your car breaks down you have the
choice to take it to the mechanic or buy
the parts from the manufacturer
and fix it yourself but when it comes to
your phone or other devices when they
break you may not have those options
so now there is a push to change that
family redwood reports
alexander degtarenko fixes phones and
other electronic devices
a big part of his business his broken
screens and battery replacements
but the repairs he can make are limited
because he has to use
third-party parts most phone makers do
not sell parts or manuals on how to fix
them
i don't think it's federal like it's
absolutely
unfair increasingly manufacturers use
all kinds of proprietary techniques to
block you from getting into your phone
kyle wiens is the ceo of ifixit which
offers repair guides for a range of
devices
he says it's not just phones it's
difficult to find parts for many
electronics
he's now part of the growing right to
repair movement
that would require manufacturers to
share the parts tools and information to
fix things
more than two dozen states are currently
considering right to repair legislation
and on wednesday the federal trade
commission voted to take on
unlawful repair restrictions advocates
say a right to repair would encourage
consumers to fix a device
instead of just buying a new one and
that would cut down on waste
some manufacturers argue against new
laws saying repair restrictions are
needed to safeguard
software and other intellectual property
but supporters say
it's time for a change we all benefit
when
repairs are more available that could
include competition
that leads to lower repair prices for
consumers
family redwood cbs news brooklyn new
york